le ciel
est étrange
le moment tant redouté est venu
et réellement de retour
j'en appelle à vous pour combattre avec
moi
travaille en main dans la main le destin
de la Terre du Milieu est entre nos
mains
nous pensions que la bataille
était désormais derrière nous
aujourd'hui
la paix se profile
nous pensions que nos joies jamais ne
finiraient
nous pensions que notre lumière jamais
ne s'éteindrait
[Musique]
le mal ne dort jamais
il patient
dans les profondeurs la pénombre peut
tous nous engloutir sous la montagne
bien des dents
tu as entendu parler de lui tu connais
le nom de
si le mal qui s'élève en Terre du Milieu
n'est pas maîtrisé il va se répandre et
tous nous anéantir
trouve la lumière et jamais l'ombre ne
te trouvera
nous pouvons gagner
combattez avec moi
chacun d'entre nous se doit de décider
quel chemin il devra emprunter
il ne peut y avoir de confiance entre un
marteau et une pierre
un bonjour
on vous a compté tant de mensonges sur
la Terre du Milieu
ravi de te revoir moi aussi mais comment
tu m'as retrouvé
regardez qui est là
Anthony green a-t-être
je n'ai pas l'intention de le laisser
s'en sortir
on dirait bien que tu un excellent
donc tu veux te battre contre
tous les deux on va le combattre
arrête de te cacher comme ça cet
adorable brunette c'est qui en
otage non non
je travaille oui
ça peut être utile
honnêtement
j'ai vu bien pire
on va faire ça à l'ancienne c'est parti
[Musique]
il en reste
j'espère que non
[Musique]
je vous aime je t'aime papa
c'est toute ta vie ma femme Maya
architecte on a décidé que ce serait
mieux que je m'occupe des enfants me
dire que c'est un système qui fonctionne
bien ok
la pêche
cool c'est bientôt mon anniv il y a
longtemps que tu en as pas fêter là
j'ai grandi depuis j'ai pas envie de
passer le week-end avec un qui est une
bande de jeunes de 22 ans j'ai une idée
pour ces vacances avata chez moi on
devrait partir à trois mais t'es jamais
partie avec les enfants sans moi je te
rappelle que c'est moi leur mère je m'en
sortirai sérieux j'ai quelques doutes
[Musique]
de passer une semaine sans leur famille
c'est mon temps libre super j'ai joué au
golf avec des copines à la retraite je
vais aller manger un barbecue improvisé
tu te sens bien ouais j'ai pété
bon anniversaire
ouais les gars dites bonjour à mon plus
vieil ami au monde
non je suis bien là
[Musique]
sous le soleil California c'est notre
Burning Man au milieu de nulle part ils
sont où les petits coins c'est là ça
c'est des potes
c'est bon je le repose
[Musique]
sauvage c'est peut-être un gros chat
mais lui ça pique déjà pitbuler ouais
t'es grave enragé
là on dirait Butch Cassidy
pas trop bien utiliser ton
temps qu'est-ce qui s'est passé tu es un
homme différent des choses dont je suis
pas très fière
des trucs débiles il faut qu'on le fasse
ensemble c'est toujours des trucs de
malade mais là je trouve que c'est tout
match allez à tout à l'heure
[Applaudissements]
ouvre tes bras en position étoile de mer
je t'avais dit que tu arriverais je
t'aime je t'aime
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je connais ma mission
c'est un message pour William Duquenne
boroscope burn monsieur Duk Kent
monsieur Duk Kent je vous appelle suite
aux lettres que vous m'avez envoyé je
sais pas très bien comment vous m'avez
trouvé vous l'être constituée à
harcèlement s'il vous plaît non envoyez
plus
c'est pas vous qui avez écrit ce livre
La machine infernale je m'en souviens
parce qu'ils avaient retiré des étagères
à cause de notre ville c'est à cause de
lui que j'ai jamais écrit de deuxième
livre
[Musique]
très controversé la machine infernale
j'en ai pas loin d'une centaine chez moi
c'est un de vos livreurs un break rouge
on a que ce type des véhicules au sein
de notre entreprise qui êtes-vous et ce
type qui a lu votre livre
il est dans une prison de haute sécurité
au Nouveau Mexique c'est pas lui il faut
arrêter de m'écrire vous comprenez alors
voulez-vous quoi William Duquesne je
vous le dirai une fois que vous m'aurez
dit ce qu'il vous voulez il voulait
savoir si j'avais vu la même chose que
lui dans ce livre il y aura un message
caché dans ce roman à la portée de tous
un réseau ne peut comprendre la démence
je me trompe grosse j'ai des tas de
questions à propos de ton livre
je sais où on en aime monsieur Ducasse
fin de l'acte 2 n'est-ce pas le moment
où le protagoniste atteint ses limites
[Musique]
veuillez vérifier le numéro et
renouvelez votre
appelez le numéro et renouveler votre
avis si vous ne savez pas les manipuler
ce seront eux qui vous manipulent
[Musique]
j'ai dit je sais pas du tout où est
l'école
Jacques Prévert c'est ça les enfants je
vous présente votre nouvelle maîtresse
elle s'appelle Marion
au revoir j'ai pas d'enseignants je
galère tous les jours vous avez baissé
les bras je vais écrire mon prénom au
tableau
je pars des vrais Français des blonds
ils sont où les blonds là je suis
sincère avec toi
avec la France
veulent filer à la Résidence harmonie
avec les Parisiens on peut pas laisser
faire et ben on va créer la première
école verte de banlieue
tu peux arrêter avec tes galettes de riz
s'il te plaît
faut la transformer cette école les
enfants ils ont besoin de sentir le
vivant la nature et on va venir implorer
le ciel on entend combien d'oiseaux là
[Musique]
écrire et compter réfléchir par même
aussi c'est pas mal tu verras
[Musique]
je viens d'ailleurs j'ai trouvé ma place
ici
[Musique]